she was uh
a great athlete um and also
extremely intelligent keith will never
know exactly what led his daughter to
take her own life
zoe had long struggled with eating
disorders like so many other young
people
she kept her social media hidden it was
only after she died that her father
found the images of self-harm
she'd been viewing online my wife got a
phone call from
from the hospital to say that uh zoe had
taken her own life
and i we rushed up to the hospital in in
uh
in aylesbury you'll never get over it
it's every day if i'd have known
what was going on in social media or
what what was being
uh was being pushed around i would have
i would have probably taken a phone away
from her the content that we saw on
there was pretty horrifying it was
fairly graphic as well some of the
images that were being sent around
the spread of disinformation and harmful
content has long dogged social media
giants
and our platforms that don't abide by a
duty of care
and remove harmful content face fines of
up to 18 million pounds
and could be blocked in the uk
altogether the rules of the game are
changing
that it is legitimate for government to
impose regulation in this area
proportionate regulation and i don't
want to impose any more regulation as
necessary i think the mere act of that
will demonstrate to tech firms they need
to up their game and then in turn
through the legislation they'll be
forced to do so
by a strong regulator in the form of
ofcom that developed very
quickly into something a bit more
sinister it's too late to help marred
she was 14 and she was groomed online
she began by talking
and later sending explicit images to
older men she'd never met
for her the new rules are long-awaited
but not enough
i didn't think anything of it it was
just innocent
to start with and then that soon
snowballed into something that was not
innocent but
it was so subtle that i didn't even
recognize it for what it was
for until like four or five years later
it is a delicate balance between freedom
of speech and protecting young people
but three years since his daughter died
for keith there is more to be done to
keep children like zoe safe
ali fordski sky news